from the printing press to the mass
production of books there's a long
history of scholars adapting to new
technologies we're used to dealing with
change in the humanities in the last 40
or 50 years the most significant advance
in our field has been the digitization
of books
this is a wonderful benefit but it's
also a challenge
given that you could have hundreds or
thousands of books available to you in
an instant where do you even start
what can we do with books now that we
couldn't before you can use tools from
data science to explore the record of
human culture in ways that just wouldn't
have been possible before whether you're
a student wanting to expand your skill
set a librarian supporting new modes of
research or a journalist who has just
received a massive cache of leaked
emails this course will show you how to
draw insights from thousands of
documents at once
in this course you'll learn the
fundamentals of text analysis a set of
techniques for manipulating the written
word that stand at the core of the
digital humanities you will learn how
with a few simple lines of code to make
use of the metadata and zero in on what
matters most research data is evidence
it's evidence that you will use to make
your case to the scientific community by
the end of the course
you'll be able to apply what you learned
what interests you most whether that's
contemporary speeches
journalism
novels or even art objects material from
across the human cultural record